hello I'm Hayden Baggett a conference
programmer at South by Southwest and I'm
excited to welcome you to our day five
Keynote
before we get to today's keynote I've
got some housekeeping notes
we're running slido today
through for our audience q a you can
find this by opening the session listing
in the South by Southwest Go app by
clicking on the engage button
on Wednesday our creative Industries
Expo will be free and open to the public
please tell your friends
after years of planning and countless
man-hours the James Webb Space Telescope
was successfully deployed last year this
Monumental achievement highlights
that perseverance and collaboration are
at the heart of what makes us human
each year We Gather from all over the
world to celebrate this core principle
at South by Southwest
with that in mind please join me in
welcoming NASA's Laura bets to the stage
who will introduce our panelists
thank you
hey how's it going I'm Laura Betts and
I'm incredibly excited to introduce you
to our unfold the universe panel
featuring scientists from NASA's James
Webb Space Telescope
with us today we have four
astrophysicists from the team
Macarena Garcia Marin Amber strong
Stephanie Milam and Nicole colon
the James Webb Space Telescope is the
largest and most complex Space Telescope
ever built this is the result of 20
000 people people from around the world
working together
Webb will solve mysteries of in our
Solar System look Beyond to Distant
Worlds around other stars and probe the
mysterious structures and origins of our
universe and our place in it Webb is an
international program led by NASA with
its Partners Issa and the Canadian space
agency
this telescope is working better than
ever expected
following its successful launch in
December 2021 and the start of science
operations in July 2022.
today we are sharing with you a
never-before-seen image from Webb I'm so
honored to be with the team that's going
to share more about this image and what
we've been learning from this powerful
telescope
here
here up on the screen is the newest
image that's come out from NASA's James
Webb Space Telescope
the beautiful wolf Ray star
Amber can you tell us a little bit more
about this image
sure I think anytime we're talking about
astronomy It's always important to think
of the concepts of context and scale you
know those of us that aren't used to
thinking about these things every day
and even those of us that are need to be
reminded and so what we're seeing in
this beautiful new image at the very
center is a star the light from that
star has been traveling through space
for about 15 000 years 15 000 light
years away until it hit the detectors on
the telescope and the material that
you're seeing around the central star
that looks like dust is dust and so at
the end of a star's life it they shed
their outer material their outer layers
out into the rest of the universe and I
think this is one of the most beautiful
Concepts in all of astronomy this is
Carl Sagan's Stardust concept the fact
that the iron in your blood and the
calcium in your bones was literally
forged inside of a star that exploded
billions of years ago and that's what
we're seeing in this new image that dust
is spreading out into the cosmos and
will eventually create planets
and this is this is how we got here in
fact
wow so beautiful Maca can you tell us a
little bit more about why this is
important sure so this Warfare Stars
they are really big and bright and
incredibly hot so they're really bold
objects this one in particular is 30
times the mass of our sun so it's very
big and when they are we know that the
stars that are this big they live fast
they go through the you know different
stages in very quick time
and some of them only some of them end
up being this Warfare to later on become
a supernova so it's really unique that
we can see and study this start with
this detail with jwst
for the first time in the infrared so as
Amber was saying this stud has shared a
lot of guys and we're talking 10 times
worth our time so it's really a lot of
material going into space and as it goes
away from the star of this gas cools
down when it cools down it forms dust
and that does when it gets colder it
glows in the infrared which is exactly
what James Webb looks at by in front of
the light so what is in front of the
light it's it's
it's a type of light we don't see with
our eyes with our eyes we see visible we
see the Reds the blues and the greens
inference it's a the fraction of the
letter is really sensitive to
temperature everything that has a
temperature from our bodies to a piece
of ice emits in the infrared and so with
it we can observe really in a very
advantages we Stellar objects so we can
there are three many bugs that
disadvantages you can see through the
Dust and the gas and then really see for
instance Australian nurseries that are
forming behind we can also see color of
this I call dust and colder planets and
we can look back in time and this is um
one of the main reasons why we build
well was to actually look at the very
first objects of the universe so when
those subjects form about
so more than 13 billion years ago they
needed light light is a wave and as it
travels through the universe through the
expanding Universe towards us it expands
like literally like a slinky
so it moves from the visible light to
the infrared light and then web can see
it as we'll see for the first time with
this details so we've never seen that
before it's really exciting oh
definitely thank you so much so this
image is just one of many that we've
seen since we've started science
operations last July the web Mission has
been so successful and has far exceeded
our expectations
let's take a look at some of these other
stunning images starting with the solar
system Stephanie can you tell us a
little bit more about this image
absolutely but before I get started I
want to wish my dad a happy birthday
today
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Jupiter this is actually the Jupiter
system and it is one of my favorite
images that we've released because it's
a lot closer to home for all of us we
will be observing the solar system with
the James Webb Space Telescope and have
been doing so and this was our first
science image that we released of
Jupiter and its system
what is so fantastic about this image is
in order to image something as big and
bright as Jupiter but also in the same
image capture the faint rings tiny
satellites and all the intricate details
of this planet means that we had to have
a factor of 10 000 in contrast so
something 10 000 brighter than like
Jupiter compared to its own rings and
satellites so it really shows the
capability of jwst and observing things
in our solar system everything from the
Aurora on the boat on either pole of
this of this planet the Great Red Spot
which is white in this image because of
the colors that we chose to depict it
and all the Fantastic detail of the
weather and in the atmosphere of Jupiter
we're going to be observing everything
in our solar system that jwst can point
to from near-earth asteroids comets
Interstellar objects all of the planets
and their satellites to the farthest
reaches of our solar system including
our favorite minor planet Pluto
so lots more to come
thank you and Nicole we've also been
able to learn more about exoplanets or
planets outside of our solar system can
you tell us a little bit more how web is
studying exoplanets and really what
we've learned so far
yeah absolutely I I wish we had as
beautiful pictures of Jupiter as we did
of these Distant Worlds but they are
very far away uh so we have to be kind
of creative in the techniques that we
used to study these distant exoplanets
and so jwst is you know a provider of
these amazing images but it also is
really great at doing something called
spectroscopy so all that really means is
we're taking the rainbow of light and
breaking it down so we can measure the
chemical Fingerprints of of objects in
the universe and so with exoplanets one
way we can study them and study their
atmospheres is by looking at ones that
pass in front of their star
and then when that happens as shown in
the animation uh what we can see is star
light blocked by the planet plus its
atmosphere so we can break down what
light gets filtered by the planet
atmosphere to reveal what the atmosphere
is made of and so using this technique
we've already made some great
discoveries with jwst so this is real
data that you're seeing here again it's
not a pretty image the the background
illustration is just an illustration of
of a giant gaseous jupiter-sized Planet
but just 700 light years away
um you know just 700. so it's pretty far
but the really neat thing about this is
we see this massive bump in the data and
what that is revealing is that the
planet plus its atmosphere is blocking
extra light from the Star and that tells
us this whopping signal is carbon
dioxide in that exoplanet atmosphere and
the reason this is so groundbreaking is
because it's the first definitive
detection of carbon dioxide outside the
solar system we know about Jupiter and
Saturn and all these planets and we can
tell their atmospheres but now we need
to learn about all these other worlds
because there are over 5000 of them out
there
miles and another thing I've been really
excited about is what we've been
learning with galaxies Maca can you tell
me a little bit more about that of
course so all planets and stars they
sort of live in neighborhoods and those
neighbors around galaxies so I like to
think of a gala's success the building
blocks of our universe there are many of
them and this beautiful image shows a
group of galaxies that are sort of
having a cosmic dance I like to think
about it so they are interacting with
each other as they get close and as you
can see here
the gravitational pull and the
neighborhood so they get so close that
it's a very slow and a very intense
process and really the stores are
galaxies creates plumes creates
beautiful extractors but it also does
create new stars and it really creates a
possibility of having from two different
galaxies
a new Galaxy that could be maybe a big
elliptical so by the end of this process
you will either have a completely new
Galaxy
another galaxy that can go away and
essentially really understand how they
form animal and at the center of each of
these galaxies we have a super massive
black hole which is also a very I mean
it's very interesting
um to me because supermassive black
holes we really don't know yet how they
are formed there's a lot of Discovery
Space in there and interaction is a very
important part of Galaxy Evolution
because we think all galaxies undergo
one of these processes at least once in
their life so it's really driven the
universe we see today so yeah it's one
of my favorites essentially thank you
unveiled by President Biden in the
summer we've been able to see Webb's
Deep Field Amber can you tell us a
little bit more about that
sure and again scale is really important
for these deep filled images
so and just to make a sort of hinted at
it but to sort of take us all back to
middle school science class right our
sun and our planets are part of the
Milky Way galaxy which has a couple
hundred billion stars just in our Milky
Way galaxy and so what we're seeing in
this image almost every single point of
light here is itself an individual
Galaxy filled with hundreds of billions
of stars and so you might think okay
well this must be like the whole sky but
actually it's not so the size of this
image on the sky would be about the size
of a grain of sand if you held it out at
arm's length so it's a very tiny piece
of sky and in this tiny piece of Sky we
see 10 000 galaxies so it sort of starts
to give you a sense of the Scale of the
Universe and in fact I think that's one
of the the most beautiful things that
these space telescopes have given us is
a sense of the the absolute enormity of
the universe
thank you and this project is the result
of two decades of hard work 14 countries
working together and 29 States
tell us a little bit more about the
journey to get here for web and what is
it doing now maca so when you want to
build and create something this
groundbreaking you really need many many
years so it took decades to
you know
decades three different agencies many
different countries thousands of people
with you know putting their minds on
brain and Ingenuity to make this
possible so from the original scientific
reason which is exactly what Amber was
now describing let's look at the first
galaxies that were formed so from that
initial concept to the sign build
Implement integration and testing and by
the way one of our most important
testing campaigns was done in Houston
here around the corner in 2017 so it's
really nice to be back it's really nice
to be in the area and here in this video
it's a celebration of I mean you see key
moments like launch you've seen moments
like integration this is in Corolla the
French Guyana and this was all thanks to
the work of the team and it really shows
how when we work together we put
together our minds and Brands as a
matter which nationality which agency it
really shows how we can achieve
essentially the achievable and really
make groundbreaking science and history
in this case
and as a result of all that web is
working better than expected it's
already starting to change our views of
the universe
why and how do you think web is really
contributing to these discoveries
Amber
well we've already talked a little bit
about about some of the the sort of big
questions that that we hope that that
jrc will answer and to go back to the
Deep Field you know one of the primary
reasons we built the telescope the way
we did was to be able to look back in
time and see that very first epic of
galaxies that were born in the Big Bang
right after the big bang so we're
talking about looking back in time over
13 and a half billion years to see a
part of space that we've never seen
before
and one of the really interesting things
that's happened you know we didn't know
what we would see right where this is
Uncharted Territory in terms of space
we've never seen it before and we hoped
that we would be able to see galaxies in
that part of space but we really didn't
know because we'd never looked and so
these first few months of data are
showing us that galaxies we are
detecting galaxies in that part of space
which is great news but the surprising
thing is is that the galaxies that we're
finding in the very very early Universe
are much bigger and much brighter than
we expected and we don't really
understand why yet so we had theories of
the early universe that told us how we
thought galaxies should grow very early
on and it turns out that our
observations don't match the theories so
and we don't know yet we don't know
what's going on and this is a really fun
place to be in science is where we're
really trying to figure it out and make
our theories match the observations so I
think that's one of the most for me I
study galaxies and how how stars and
black holes grow in galaxies so so this
is my favorite topic but I think one of
the most surprising things that we've
already discovered in just the first few
months of operations is the fact that
these galaxies you know grew really fast
and really big so it's it's really
interesting we don't know why
thanks and for you Nicole
yeah you know with uh exoplanets again
we've talked about the first detection
of carbon dioxide outside our solar
system but going beyond that we've
already seen that jwst data is is just
so good and so precise that we are able
to detect additional molecules in these
distant exoplanet atmospheres that we've
never really expected to see one of
those is sulfur dioxide which is
actually created in the same way Earth's
ozone layer is created it's a
photochemical process and there's these
reactions these chemical reactions
happening in the atmospheres that we
just literally didn't think we'd be able
to see them with jwst even though we
knew it would be great telescope you
know it was still just that much better
than expected and we're so excited I
mean even these initial detections that
we're making they're already rewriting
the textbooks for our understanding of
the composition like going from galaxies
and formation time scales to exoplanet
information and solar system you know in
every scale we are rewriting textbooks
like every day
and I'm curious
what was it like what was the feeling
that you had when you saw that first web
image
Stephanie so uh for me
um one of the first images that I I got
to see was obviously the Karina nebula
and this is just um one of the most the
most breathtaking image I would argue
that we've had to date
um we can argue about that later
but it's just it's spectacular in every
form and it's artistic it is it is
beautiful but it's also just bursting
with science and Discovery also if it's
not your background of your phone or
your computer screen
um
clearly have not been paying attention
but at any rate so what we're learning
about even when this first image came in
so beyond its beauty
um I had to take a moment I had to pause
because
already I could see the Discovery Space
just coming out of this the science
there we were told we weren't allowed to
science the images that were being
released in the first uh the first set
of images and it was so hard to sit
there and keep your mouth shut about all
the things that we can see already the
Discovery Space the new the new ways
that we can see Star formation and plant
information happening it's like
happening in this picture and uh it was
it was an emotional experience the
culmination of you know the multiple
Decades of people working together to
build this telescope the six months of
day in and day out commissioning waiting
for these images to be released
um it was a lot of energy and it was
just a lot of relief and it was a lot of
excitement so um I'm just excited for
more to happen yes
anyone else any thoughts you had
go ahead
very similarly so
um for me my first image was
um when we were you know launcher
started to switch on the instruments
switch on the detectors and you start to
get this first engineering images that
obviously are not as beautiful as this
one but they already indicated how well
everything was working and at some point
um there was all the work of making all
the mirrors assignment and mirrors to
work as a single one I'm assure you all
saw that first
sort of again engineering image showing
a very bright sharp star in the center
which was like it is working so well and
it's really going Beyond expectations
but also you could see around all these
little tiny galaxies that personally I
didn't expect to be so many of them like
all the photobombing galaxies and really
it's it's all about
often we were thinking like a
preparation for commissioning oh we need
to observe an isolated Galaxy to do this
or that there are no I saw that they got
isolated stars with web everything is
surrounded by galaxies and by more
um you know sources that are there we
need to to explore so it was a great
experience and of course a combination
of Stephanie was saying was this
beautiful set of images that was
released for the public to enjoy and to
really see why it was worth it but also
for the community the scientific
Community to really dig in the data and
start making science and start taking
advantage and learning about a new
Mission and your telescope that we
launched last year so um yeah it was
very good
and Nicole how did that moment make you
feel
I mean it's similar to you know what's
been said it's literally these pictures
are full of just unimagined detail you
know if you download the high-res
versions you can zoom and scroll for
days you know and discover new features
and it's incredible to know that
in these first images alone you know
it's only the beginning and we're
already seeing evidence of new stars
forming galaxies everywhere
um baby planets that could be forming
and it was just unreal and you know very
humbling that you know we all did get to
take part in this amazing journey to
help get those images out to the public
last summer and we were all involved in
the six-month commissioning like around
the clock work as well just to get these
ready
um it was so it was a lot of hard work
but it was so worth it and you know it's
just yeah you almost have no words to
describe
and in Amber how like what was going
through your head during that moment
yeah I mean similarly I think one of the
most fun Parts was just being the part
of the like behind the scenes team that
was was getting the telescope ready for
you know for its public debut but you
know we got to see um the the
engineering images that came came
through during that six-month
commissioning period which was a very
intense time of getting the telescope
ready for operations and so for me being
part of you know being part of that team
that was working together to get the
telescope working was was really
incredible and then yeah when we
released these first images
um it's just you know from a scientific
standpoint like Stephanie was saying you
know you could see the richness you
could see the detail the things we'd
never seen before but on a more human
level I think for me it was good to just
like to sort of Step Back From My
scientist Persona and just take in the
beauty of these images you know they're
beautiful on a deep human level and so
for me it was it was it was emotional
you know I I think a lot of us were like
we all cried we saw the images the first
time you know they're they're um
they're you know undoubtedly very
beautiful
tell me a little bit more of some of the
other new discoveries that we've been
seeing
so um Beyond you know the the farthest
galaxies and you know planets around
other stars and exploring our solar
system one area that we're really
um getting a lot of new information and
already a lot of science out of is the
birth of stars so understanding star
formation in a way that we've never
really had access to we don't know how
massive stars are formed we don't know
how small stars or binary Stars we don't
know how all these complex new planetary
systems we're now seeing how they're
formed and when we look inside these
giant clouds of gas and dust we're
seeing that Dynamic actually happening
we can study the chemistry we can study
the physics and again it's just with
this whole new sensitivity and detail
that we've never had before not only are
we studying star formation in our own
Galaxy but even in other galaxies so
even what we're seeing here in the
cartwheel image we're seeing these
galaxies are colliding but it's also
triggering all kinds of new stars to be
born and formed and we're getting this
detail now that we used to only have on
our own Galactic understanding now
expanding into these other galaxies
Across the Universe and it's just really
an exciting time to be part of that
field and understand how our son was
born and how the solar system was was
formed and this is giving us that first
real glimpse of it
and when it comes to galaxies like what
more are we learning here
with JW is to the thing is that many of
these colors say that the card wheel
that you can see now on the screen they
are close
so you would think well is it
quote-unquote worth or serving it with
web and the answer is absolutely yes
because we are seeing it so much detail
and in-depth studies so in this case for
instance you see how this galaxy has
this very strange shape uh like a whale
and this is because it did undergo many
years ago a very strong and fast
Collision essentially with a smaller
Galaxy that sort of went through and
created that those spokes that were
originally the spiral arms of the first
Galaxy so what we can see is studying
galaxies is we do have at hand the
perfect laboratory to study with jwst
how galaxies
form evolve and essentially how to start
form inside you have to put together all
that information from the detail studies
from the solar system from you know from
the solar system to the nearby
um esteroform areas in our galaxy and
then extrapolate those two galaxies and
then you have to put together
at the environment how do formula Stars
affects environment it creates filaments
it create new stars they evolve into
supernovas we're going to start studying
we do a study materials that are
essential for the formation of both the
stars and planets and at the core of the
galaxies we do have the super massive
black holes that they have a very
intimate interplay with their
environment and in many cases they are
is active they shine so bright that it
literally outshines the whole Ambassador
emission of the Galaxy so there are many
advantages to to study galaxies because
when you understand your local galaxies
you can then say okay now let's see if
this model we have in mind fits to older
galaxies in time so it's really putting
together many pieces of the puzzle with
detail never seen before in the infrared
absolutely and one thing that really
strikes me with these images is how much
they Inspire us all to wonder really
there's an explorer at the heart of
everyone and these images have allowed
us to really explore the unknown
together
why do you feel like this is so
important Amber and why is this so
inspirational
well I think one of the main reasons
that's important is that jwst shows us
that we can do you know very difficult
big bold you know almost impossible
things when we're all working together
for something good and I think astronomy
is good you know I think in a in a real
sense you know we're we're living in a
difficult time right now as a world as a
species and for me last summer I feel
like
those releasing those images was like
this breath of fresh air it was
something good and I think that these
telescopes are something good that we
that we can do for the world and as as
far as inspiration goes you know one of
the things I love most about astronomy
in general is that astronomy gets to the
heart of our big questions you know
where do we come from and how do we get
here and are we alone you know those big
questions that are more than just Arcane
science questions there are questions
that get to the heart of what it means
to be human and I think all of us have
the common experience of of looking up
at a dark night sky and it's just sort
of intuitively asking those big
questions and I think these telescopes
help help push us forward and
understanding more about our world you
know it's a fundamental part of being a
human being is to explore and discover
and they help us with that
and building the mission launching it
and commissioning it has been a hugely
International project
this is such a feat how's that been for
you to collaborate to make this happen
haka
for me it's been the best part of
experience so my whole career has been
based on on web essentially uwc working
in different places different capacities
but all the way through
for me the best part of it was getting
together with a team working the problem
seeing what to do next and really
planning to to have this amazing
telescope we have out and when I go
Amber essentially this really shows how
we are all at our best when you put you
know all our brains and all our effort
together to do something this is
spectacular so it's been
it's been a gift personally to to be
able to be part of this team and to
enjoy it
thanks Stephanie what's been the most
rewarding part of this awe-inspiring
project for you
there's so many to choose from
um I think it's probably been the most
rewarding getting to work part of as
part of this huge team I mean 20 000
people over two decades
um I've been on the project just barely
over 10 years and what I've learned from
those the individuals that have been
working on this for almost 30 years I
gained so much information Insight
knowledge and it has been fantastic to
be part of this huge team and watch how
they've worked together work through our
issues our challenge is and deliver the
best infrared Space Telescope that we
ever had
thanks now let's go back to those
challenges so to get to this point you
probably faced a lot of challenges and I
just am curious were there any role
models that you felt helped you get to
this point
Nicole
yeah I mean there's well I'll start by
saying I mean my parents are huge role
models they are not scientists they're
not involved with the James Webb Space
Telescope but they always had have had
and still have you know an amazing work
ethic and that is part of it like you
know perseverance basically to get
through challenges and I mean I can
speak to my personal experience I mean
the project yeah it had a lot of
challenges over time but I was
relatively new to the project adjoining
in late 2019 and you know if you might
recall what happened a few months later
a pandemic started and you know it was
hard to get caught up in all of those
um with with the Decades of experience
you know it was very humbling
um and a great challenge but still an
exciting challenge like you know Amber
was saying it's worth it like to be able
to share and to get this telescope out
to share the universe with the world
um and so a lot of you know nobody said
anything or particular to me I guess I
mean I will say our team is very
supportive overall so it was really
great to be able to work with you know
be one of 20 000 people working on the
project and even playing a tiny role to
help get this mission where it is today
um but you know I definitely have my
parents to thank over the years they
never gave up on me or my siblings and
that really helped push us along I mean
you know just to add one more thing you
know I never did the best in school like
I didn't have the greatest grades at
times I had professors say they were
literally disappointed in me and I'm
like but you know what I can do it right
if I I knew I wanted to work at Nasa one
day I was going to make it happen and so
it's all about perseverance um and
overcoming these major challenges so for
me personally but also I think that's a
good theme for the project as a whole
you know everybody working together to
get through various obstacles that we
had including launching during a
pandemic
thank you
and for you Amber
yeah so challenges I mean yeah um I I
grew up in rural Arkansas and so I was
not surrounded by a lot of scientists um
but similar to Nicole my parents were
huge supporters my mom was always like
my biggest cheerleader
um but yeah there were definitely
challenges to growing up you know in a
place where there wasn't a lot of you
know actual you know real life scientist
Role Models but parents were supportive
and you know I grew up uh during the
shuttle program at Nasa and I was in the
fifth grade when Hubble launched and you
know all of that stuff happening at Nasa
in my childhood made me really want you
know want to be a part of it and a a
definite upside of growing up where I
did was the sky was dark beautiful and
dark and that's how I get into astronomy
to begin with
um and so yeah similarly to Nicole I I
had my own challenges you know getting
through school
um I I felt my big physics test to get
my PhD the first time I had to take it
again you know we have all these silly
mantras like failures not an option but
you know that's not true
um you know failure happens when you're
doing hard things you're gonna have
moments of failure and I think that's
true personally it's definitely been
true in this project you know we had
engineering setbacks um but we we
figured them out we persevered we got it
in space and now it's working better
than than we ever expected
and what was the big driver for you in
your career Maca like what what really
inspires you about being a scientist
personally I get very what drives me
daily it's the challenge itself that
problem solving we are all problem
solvers would like to take something
hard as Amber was saying and try to see
how to either understand it also but
this is an issue so personally it's all
about
you know we have this observation that
doesn't fit Theory then you have to go
back to your drawing board and really
try to understand what is going on we
have some technical issue with whatever
part of the integration of satellite so
then you have to go back figure it out
and solve it so it's all that constant
um
interesting process it's really
scientific process that I really enjoy
and I feel that's my driver it really
makes life very interesting and you know
the four of us could see this if the
same problem exactly in four different
ways and probably by talking to each
other I would find like a perfect
solution for that so it's really it's
great
problem solving and collaboration thank
you and what are you most looking
forward to Stephanie
uh the unknown unknown
um every time we look at one of these
fantastic new images Spectra or
otherwise we're we're seeing things that
we've never seen before and that's
bringing out the Curiosity and the
challenges that we have as scientists to
say why did that happen how did that
happen what's making that happen what's
the evolution of this process and what
can we learn from it and every time we
do that and we've been doing this for
you know
hundreds of years as astronomers as
scientists as as humans every time we
look and we have a curiosity about
something we look harder and I think
this first year first couple of years of
science with jwst is going to open the
door to huge new questions and
challenges that we have ahead of us on
you know the evolution of the Galaxy
whether or not there could be life on
another planet whether there's life in
the solar system all of these things are
challenges that are put forward to us
and we're doing the best that we can and
but sometimes we think that we can do it
better so we build bigger and better
telescopes we build we collaborate with
International Teams because sometimes
these projects are bigger than just one
person and I think the new discoveries
the unknown unknowns is what I'm the
most excited about with web would you
like to add to that Nicole
yeah it's been what less than a year you
know of Science and every image every
spectrum that we're getting it's just
changing the way we view the universe
because it's a really new information
and a lot of what I study or involves
exoplanets these Distant Worlds outside
the solar system and you know a lot of
what I've talked about today I mentioned
today was these gas giant like
jupiter-sized planets that we've been
studying but there are many smaller
rocky planets that we are looking to
study with jwst it's already studying
some of these and I'm excited to see you
know what we learn about those planets
that are around the same size as our own
you know they might not always be the
same temperature you know they might not
have
surfaces with liquid oceans and all that
but we expect to still learn about their
overall atmosphere and you know is there
water in the atmosphere is there carbon
dioxide is there anything familiar to us
that we can connect to and relate to to
help us understand better of you know
is there other life out there you know
what can jwst reveal and it's also
helping set the stage for for future
NASA goals as well
and this telescope really belongs to the
world could you tell me a little bit
more Amber about who's using this and
like how this is for everyone
yeah I think you mentioned Laura in your
in your introduction that this telescope
was the result of 14 different countries
working together uh so Engineers from
you know all over the world built it in
an even larger number of astronomers
from all over the world are already
using its data but I think you know
beyond the engineers and the scientists
that actively use the telescope and
built the telescope it really is for all
of us I think astronomy is for all of us
and and these these beautiful images
um they're all by the way available
freely available online you can go
download all of them and I think it
really does does show that that these
these beautiful images in astronomy are
here to inspire us to think outside of
ourselves and to think bigger
thank you so much I really am so
appreciative of you all being here today
and now we're going to take some
questions
so here we go
oh this is a great question
is there extraterrestrial intelligent
life I want to believe Max Payne
uh do you want me to this I could go for
it sorry
okay I was just yeah talking about you
know the potential for for jwst to at
least study Rocky you know earth-sized
planets um
but is there actually extraterrestrial
intelligent life there could be life is
it intelligent you know is there
intelligent life on Earth no
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I guess it depends on you know the the
how you Define intelligent but I think
uh I want to believe too I guess is the
bottom line there's so many there's
billions of stars out there which means
there are billions of planets so you
know and it's more serious answer I
think
there just has to be you know otherwise
again a Carl Sagan quote like it's a
waste of space if humans are the only
intelligent life in the universe
another question how long does it take
to plan position and take a single photo
Peter Dwyer thanks for that question
yeah thanks well
um
like everything it depends typically all
the data that is taking in a year all
the scientific programs are prepared by
the you know scientific Community they
send their proposals and they get
approved so that preparation takes place
perhaps
a year or more than the observation is
taking so when it's approved it goes
into the scheduling and say your
observation is going to happen tomorrow
so depending on the object and depending
on how bright or how faint it is it can
take any time from you know one hour to
tens of hours it really depends what
you're seeing if you are interested in
solar system targets like Stephanie
it'll take typically half an hour to get
to your target from you know when when
it's planned and very little time to get
a very sharp image but the sort of the
and then you have to if the source is
very big you have to you know do many
shots and do like a mosaic but yeah it's
um it's a very sensitive telescope but
it really depends on what you're looking
at
I think one of the um just to add on to
that one of the awesome things about
this telescope is how sensitive it is
how efficient it is so you know we we
have these beautiful deep fields from
Hubble um like the Hubble Ultra Deep
Field and if you look at those images
from Hubble which are beautiful and
taught us incredible things about the
universe they took days you know 14 20
days of observing and we saw on that
very first image that we released last
summer of the Deep Field that we got an
image that was even deeper in the
infrared in just hours of time and so
really the the the the power of this
telescope is how efficient it is in its
observational capabilities
thanks we have another question from
Colleen Berg
what do you mean by the colors we choose
to depict can you expand on that process
and why don't we see it as it is
so uh as was explained we have an
infrared telescope and not a telescope
that operates at wavelengths of light
that you can see so visible light the
way the Hubble telescope does so in
order for us to understand and study any
of these given objects at these longer
wavelengths of Light which our eyes are
not sensitive to we hone in on colors
and we label those colors as to define a
given physical process or chemical
process so that we can study those
details in ways that our eyes can
actually see because when these images
come in they're they're black and white
it's it's a series of you know ones and
zeros lots lots of pixels and we take a
picture with a given filter and we take
another picture of the same spot with
another filter and we just color one
filter green one filter red one filter
blue and each of those filters are
telling us something different about
that object and we just give them those
colors based on we try to follow the
same color coordination as visible light
so longer wavelengths we tend to color
more red shorter wavelengths we tend to
color more blue but it doesn't
necessarily have to be that way it's
just a way that we try to standardize
when we make these beautiful images that
you see here but if I was looking at an
object in the solar system I might
choose different colors just to
highlight certain types of phenomena
that are happening in in Jupiter's
atmosphere for example I could totally
label the great red spot as red in that
image but there's other things there's
other Dynamic processes happening in
Jupiter for example that we wanted to
emphasize and that's why those filters
were chosen and those colors were chosen
thanks and another question very similar
from hi nukin how does the team decide
where to point the telescope
anybody
yeah so the team doesn't understand
essentially this is a telescope for the
world so the way it works right now
after we did commissioning and then the
team decided because it was all about
you know the
setting the instruments and really
demonstrating good to the science but
now for science for science operations
the way it works that once a year
typically there is a call for proposals
and the entire scientific Community is
invited to
send their ideas you could send you know
I want to use this instrument I will
serve this Target and this is the
science I want to achieve and then all
those proposals and this year it was
closed recently and we received like
1700 so no
1600.
so this will be reviewed by several
panels of experts in all the different
scientific topics and it's an
interesting process because it is double
blind so the reviewer doesn't know who
is submitting the proposal or which team
is submitting it which is really great
because it removes a lot of biases so
the panels aside and they rank the
proposals and you know the top ones are
the ones that make it into the schedule
but it's all merit-based and
scientifically interesting proposals um
other ones that are chosen
and I think even one of the awesome
things about these telescopes that I
think a lot of people don't maybe don't
realize is that so yeah an astronomers
say they were one of the lucky ones that
got their awesome proposal awarded and
so
um it depends on the program but
typically that astronomer and their team
will get a year with the data then after
a year the data is public to everybody
absolutely and a lot of the programs
especially during this first year of
operations have no proprietary period so
that means as soon as the data is is is
you know downloaded the telescope and in
in the world it's in the world for
everybody anyone can use it and a lot of
the early teams have made the choice and
in the solar system team decided you
know we could keep this data but we're
going to make it public for everyone so
we can learn as much as as we can about
about the telescope how it's operating
and about the science and so and that's
another sense in in which these
telescopes really are for the entire
world
thanks and Carly free has a question any
clues as to what space is telling us
about the future of Earth
yeah that's a broader question I mean it
could be James was specific
um it's but that's a really good
question I mean there's different ways
that we're studying
um planets including everything in our
solar system as well as asteroids
comments like the building blocks of our
solar system and then we're studying
over 5 000 exoplanets that are arranging
anything from similar in size to Earth
to Jupiter size so we have a great
sample that continues to increase as
we're studying uh exoplanets and you
know what we do want to do is compare
those
systems and say do they have any
similarities to Earth you know what is
their relation I mean Earth is
um like a middle-aged star Earth this
our sign is a middle-aged star so Earth
is a middle-aged Planet if you will and
we are studying planets that are around
younger stars and around some older
stars too so I think we're still very
much in the early days of you know
deciphering all the exoplanet data to
see okay could any of them be you know
like a future earth right and but I will
say Mars is a great example of you know
closer to home that maybe Stephanie you
want to elaborate on is a potential way
that Earth could evolve in the future
yeah I can add a few thoughts on that as
well um so our Earth has looked very
different so if we had the James Webb
Space Telescope when the sun was was
formed and the planets were formed in
our solar system
um if we were looking at our solar
system the Earth
back then in the early the early days
looked very very different from what it
looks like today and it has evolved and
changed dramatically during the
evolution of our solar system you can
think about the heavy bombardment era
where everything just kind of got blown
off of the surface of the Earth even
before you know the first signs of life
we had very different atmosphere so
while Nicole's studying planets around
other stars and studying their
atmospheres who's to say that that
planet's not going to evolve to
something like what earth looks like
today we're getting these instantaneous
snapshots of of things that happened
billions of years ago sometimes or
hundreds of thousands of years ago so
who knows what they are today in real
time we can look at our history we can
look at other planets in our solar
system and see how they've been affected
impacted by their own Evolution Mars
being a fantastic example once having
huge oceans and lakes we see that with
the the rocks on Mars we see you know
riverbed like rocks that are rounded
from processing of liquid water flowing
on the surface these are things that
give us all the clues of how our planet
might actually evolve and if we don't
take care of it we might have a lot more
detrimental effects sooner than later
thanks and Louise percini asks how can
James Webb help us Advance the
understanding of Cutting Edge Mysteries
like dark matter dark energy
Etc
uh yeah so Louise knows his astrophysics
good job
um so so yeah I guess again to zoom out
so
we think that about 75 of the
um
whole energy matter content of the
universe is this mysterious thing that
we call dark energy and another 20 is
this other mysterious stuff called Dark
Matter so you're noticing a trend here
right when astronomers don't know what
something is we label it dark and so uh
but it's it's astounding so all of these
things we've been discussing today you
know the the hundreds of billions of
galaxies and the trillions of stars and
countless planets all of that only makes
up about five percent of the whole
universe and the rest the other 95
percent
we don't know what it is uh and so there
are ways that jrst is going to help us
in learning about specifically about
dark matter because you can sort of
think of dark matter as the scaffolding
of the universe it's it's the
scaffolding on which the galaxies sit
and so by studying how how galaxies
evolve uh over time we're able to learn
more about how dark matter behaves and
so in that sense of studying how
galaxies change over time we can learn
more about Dark Matter Dark Energy we
can we can also study Dark Energy with
Shady risk tea in some of the similar
ways we've done so with Hubble but we're
actually building another telescope
that's going to launch in 2027 called
the Nancy Grace Roman Space Telescope
and we're already building it already
testing it things are going great and
that particular telescope is
specifically designed to study Dark
Energy so we should be learning a lot
more about Dark Energy later on down the
road with the Nancy Grace Roman Space
Telescope
thanks and David frager asks what is the
expected lifespan of web
Stephanie okay sure
um so we we built this telescope with a
requirement so NASA had to deliver a
space infrared telescope that worked for
five years
we also were told that we had to carry
about 10 years worth of fuel we do have
a fuel limited Mission as we were
launching that was our our plan was once
we ran out of fuel to maintain where we
are
um a million miles away from Earth and
to unload momentum that would be the end
of mission
fortunately because of our fantastic
colleagues who helped us launch our
telescope into space on an Arion 5
rocket
we had such a nominal launch
nominal just doesn't say the words it
was absolutely Flawless our launch was
so perfect you could not see the error
bars and what we hope to do versus what
we actually did
um and even in our first images that we
had of the telescope once it detached
from the spacecraft and started drifting
on its Journey
we saw our first deployment happen we
saw the solar array unfold which meant
the launch was so perfect we didn't even
have to tweak which way the telescope
was pointing it was already pointing in
the right direction already going on its
journey and it automatically started
deploying itself because I knew that
everything was perfect
so our calculations after our launch
after our insertion into the orbit that
we're in
um gave us estimates of 20 years of
science Mission lifetime which is
fantastic for the Next Generation
[Applause]
fingers crossed all the instruments work
that long fingers crossed you know we
don't have any other major setbacks with
the observatory I mean we have a giant
sunshield that's made out of basically
happy birthday balloons so you know we
are a little fragile
um but we're doing the best we can to
maintain and operate our telescope in a
safe way so that we will have science
for many decades
so thanks and Anonymous asks what's been
the most wow moment in each of your
career so far
PS love seeing an all-woman panel for a
hardcore stem topic girls get it done
[Applause]
I mean I could start by saying this is
the most wow moment
you know it's no honestly I think
um it's hard because working at Nasa is
just a lot of fun and we do get a lot of
wow moments like I'm very grateful for
that in the sense that we get to work on
all kinds of really amazing space
missions and get them out to the public
so that we can you know share these
incredible data with you and explore the
universe together so
in a way almost every day is a wow
moment
um when we're working on these missions
but I so that's not really you know one
single moment but I feel like there's so
many it's hard to pick one
anybody else want to have anything
I can pick one no
so for me my one moment was definitely
the day of launch like there was so much
at the stake you know so many years so
much effort that has put into that so
many dreams and hopes into that mission
that it was really fantastic to see it
so nominal and boring quote unquote it
was perfect and it was a very enjoyable
moment and and I really treasure that
and then of course everything after it
Nicole is right we are lucky and there
are many great moments but for me
personally the day of launch was
fantastic really
I think we have time for a couple more
questions our Conde writes NASA science
is rewriting science books at an
increasing and accelerating great a good
problem it agency exploring new ways to
disseminate all this
thank you
um sure yeah I mean NASA really takes
seriously I think it's role to explain
what we're doing to the public uh and I
think you know all of us that are
involved in these missions really try
hard to to do that I mean this is a good
example
um of one of the ways that we try to do
that but yeah the agency is always
trying to to think of of new ways to you
know to get to get our information and
our data out out to the rest of the
world
um you know I think I think it's it's
forward-looking in a lot of ways you
know NASA was one of the first maybe the
first government agency to really
Embrace social media
um and so I think I think that there's a
lot that our Communications teams uh do
which Laura is a part of thank you Laura
um that you know our Communications
teams are fantastic and work really
really hard at making sure that we can
make the science understandable and get
it out to the world
thanks and let's see
if we go no new question
uh what kinds of discoveries are we
hoping to see in the next couple months
foreign
so I can say we have a lot of fantastic
work that's coming out from the the
telescope
um now that we're just sort of almost
finished with our first year of science
operations the science Community is
really working hard on analyzing their
own data and putting it into scientific
peer-reviewed publication the way that
we are supposed to do and we get paid to
do
and so that is now finally coming out
and it's coming to fruition so lots of
science is coming out in the literature
that's come from the James Webb Space
Telescope we have a queue of how many
press releases for future Publications
that are that are coming out so it is
very exciting time
um Amber and I get a lot of the behind
the scenes looks at some of those things
and just seeing the new science and the
new discoveries on the horizon
um just stay tuned I mean every week we
release something so uh just follow us
and I'm sure you'll you'll be astounded
and I want to thank you all so much for
being here today and for everyone
following along
and thank you
and if you want to follow along more for
more updates on NASA's James Webb Space
Telescope check out our social media at
Nasa web thank you so much
[Applause]